Remember that the whole area under the curve in terms of proportions is 1. And
therefore, if 95% or 0.95 is between negative 2 and 2. Remember, these are the z
scores. And same with this skinny normal distribution. 95% is between two
standard deviations below, and two standard deviations above the mean. So, that
must mean that the remaining proportions here, are 1 minus .95, which is 0.05.
So, a proportion of 0.05, or 5%, is either below 2 or above 2 standard
deviations. That means then that since this data is symmetrical, 2.5% is on this
tail and 2.5% is on this tail, same here. You don't have to memorize this. If
you know that 68% is within one standard deviation, and 95% is within two, you
can always know the percentage, or the proportion in between any two integer
standard deviations for the mean. We're going to practice that now.